en
e
et
les retours semblent se passer mieux que
prévu sur les routes de la toussaint on
peut fermer ou à sec hausse de l'essence
dans la confusion
7 10 3 ou 10 3 sets c'est le tiercé 2400
francs dans l'ombre
jerry ford et jimmy carter au seuil de
la maison blanche lequel passera la
pente notre dossier est entre messieurs
bonsoir à la veille de l'élection
présidentielle américaine bien malin
l'institut de sondages ou l'éminent
politologue qui pourrait dire qui de
ford ou de carter va l'emporter
2 les seules certitudes c'est d'une part
que le peuple américain jusqu'au bout
s'est désintéressé de la compétition et
que cela se retrouvera demain dans les
bureaux de vote avec un taux
d'abstention certainement très élevée et
d'autre part que la fin de la campagne a
plutôt desservi jimmy carter et faire
regagner un peu de terrain à jay ralph
or nous ferons une large place et c'est
naturel à ce duel ford carter dans la
deuxième partie de ce journal avec en
particulier le portrait des deux
candidats préparé par jacques séguin en
france à cette heure ci on se bouscule
encore un peu sur les routes comme vous
allez pouvoir le constater dans un
instant sur ces images il ya beaucoup de
monde
fils en particulier dans la région
parisienne mais tout de même pas de gros
problèmes en tout cas moins que prévu
pourtant les ordinateurs avaient annoncé
des retours très difficile ce soir s'ils
le sont un peu moins que prévu c'est que
la rentrée des classes ne coïncident pas
cette année avec les retours de week-end
il faut dire cependant que beaucoup de
français se sont rendus comme le veut la
tradition sur les tombes de leurs
familles de leurs amis à la campagne ou
en province donc des retours à prévoir
tout de même jusqu'à demain au moins
vous savez que deux augmentations en
particulier vous attendent les sens je
vais y revenir et la vignette cette
vignette 1977 que voici a été mise en
vente aujourd'hui celle ci vaut 150
francs contre 100 francs l'année
dernière pour une voiture de cinq à sept
chevaux 100 francs de un à quatre
chevaux vous allez voir le petit tableau
400 francs de 8 11 chevaux 700 francs de
douze à seize chevaux souci pour les
voitures récentes et vous savez que si
votre véhicule à plus de 5 ans vous
paierez demi tarif quant à l'essence et
bien je vous le rappelle elle passe
cette nuit à zéro heure de 1 franc 96 à
deux francs 25 pour le super d'offres en
86 à deux francs 09 pour l'ordinaire et
le gasoil augmente de 4 centimes 1
francs 34 litres avec un billet de 50
francs on peut aujourd'hui pratiquement
faire le plein d'un réservoir moyens
cela fait 25 litres et demi de super
demain avec l'augmentation le bidon ne
contiendra plus que 22,2 litres
la différence ne paraît pas très
importante à première vue pourtant
prenez une voiture moyenne consomme en
10 litres aux 100 km sur autoroute
voici ce que cela donne pour un trajet
comme paris nice
environ 900 kilomètres donc 90 litres de
super qui ce soir valsant 76 francs avec
cette somme demain vous ne dépasserez
kpn aix en provence ou n'aurait fait que
7 184 km au lieu des 900 prévu cette
fois-ci l'augmentation paraît énorme et
c'est bien là le but recherché
ce soir les fonctionnaires de
l'industrie et des finances se demandent
s'ils n'ont pas connu une commis une
petite erreur tactique car en annonçant
plusieurs jours à l'avancé et avant un
week end très chargé sur le plan de la
circulation des hausses de carburant
ils ont involontairement bien entendu
provoquer un double phénomène d'abord la
ruée des automobilistes sur les stations
service histoire de faire le plein à
l'ancien tarif est ensuite la fermeture
d'un très grand nombre de distributeurs
dont certains espéraient peut-être
spéculer en écoulant à partir de mardi
aux nouveaux tarifs du carburant acheté
à l'ancien prix voire dans les deux
serres ce n'est pas une référence formel
cela s'est passé un peu partout
aujourd'hui en france il y à thouars 15
stations service une seule était ouverte
ce matin
une deuxième a ouvert ses pompes en
début d'après-midi un sur ce lundi de
toussaint et jours fériés mais
normalement au moins six stations aurait
dû être ouverte pour assurer le service
les gendarmes ont été amenés à constater
cet état de fait et si des sanctions
sont prises comme l'annoncent le
ministère de l'industrie et spéculateurs
devront s'expliquer car et c'est évident
les pompistes avait tout intérêt à
conserver leurs stocks jusqu'à minuit
l'explication en est sain c'est les
approvisionnements que vous avez eu
jusqu'à maintenant étaient tarifées
l'ancien tarif c'est à dire au prix de
l'essence 1,96 si vous vous rendez à
partir de demain ça va être à 2.25 c'est
tout bénéfice c'est quoi du bénéfice on
peut effectivement jouer sur les mots
mais si ce n'est pas faire du bénéfice
que de vendre de l'essence acheté pour 1
franc 96 à 2.25 cela y ressemble
étrangement
en tout cas de nombreux automobilistes
ont été contraints de faire
d'interminables queues pour remplir leur
réservoir presque toujours
l'incompréhension était de rigueur entre
eux et les pompes
monsieur vous avez l'air un peu en
colère de fer devoir faire la queue on
prend par le vent les temps n'est pas
ouvert les pompes ses jours alors que en
principe on me dit que le père d'un
million banon pour pâques et les avances
d'accord c'est possible on les plaint
mais c'était trop bien on perdra million
à chacun cela dit choisir comme date
celle des retours de vacances de la
toussaint et surtout de l'annoncé cela
devait provoquer des remous
c'est pour faire une décision qui n'a
pas été prise à la légère alors que
c'est une décision de caractère
politique les ministres concernés
éventuellement premier ministre prenne
la décision est correspondante
quand on prend une décision qui le cas
échéant peut prêter à spéculation par
exemple quand on évalue la monnaie on
s'entoure du secret justement pour
décourager les spéculateurs pourquoi
annoncé à grand renfort de publicité de
longs jours à l'avancé que l'essence va
augmenter si vous voulez je crois que la
situation relativement clair au niveau
des grandes sociétés de raffinage
il ne peut pas y avoir de spéculation
car c'est une simple augmentation de
taxes que qu'elle livre les sens avant
ou après le 1er novembre à minuit pour
elle l'art et c'était exactement la même
et donc il ne peut pas y avoir d'action
anormal de ce côté là au niveau des
détaillants comme quoi je vous le dis
les choses sont claires nous avons pris
les dispositions avec le cct raffinage
pour que sur les transats prestations
offertes par ailleurs bien soin
l'existant alimentation départementale
est appliquée soit ce sont des accords
amiables et les situations anormales à
l'égard de ces accords amiables et de la
façon dont il fonctionne est
habituellement seront corrigés vous
souvenez-vous de cette pièce de théâtre
dans laquelle jacques fabbri s'escamote
bout de champ c'est la pagaille la
pagaille et de rire gaillardement on a
bien envie de l'imiter a constaté les
ordres contre-ordre contretemps
malentendu fausse manoeuvre est vrai
combines qui ont précédé la hausse des
carburants la pagaille c'est vrai mais
je doute que les gens en panne sèche est
autant envie de rire que jacques fabbri
il n'y a jamais eu autant de monsieur
avec chacun une responsabilité
particulière il y aura bientôt à
monsieur deux roues par et il est
apparemment autant d'incompétence car
enfin les français en ce qu'ils sont qui
pouvait douter qu annoncé que l'essence
augmenterait de 30 centimes le lendemain
d'un long week end allait provoquer un
rush sur les pompes faire le plein ce
soir d'une voiture moyenne représente 15
francs d'économies
les temps sont durs messieurs qui peut
s'indigner par ailleurs que des patrons
de stations service et eu la tentation
et y ait succombé de passer là tout ça
en famille en sachant bien que demain en
vendant le carburant plus cher on
rattraperait largement le manque à
gagner d'aujourd'hui après tout ces gens
là ne sont pas des saints et le sommes
donc stricte affaire de gouvernement
dont c'est bien connu la fonction est de
prévoir et avant tout de prévoir les
réactions des gouvernés cela dit mettons
à son crédit le souci de n'avoir pas
voulu alourdir financièrement ce
week-end traditionnellement consacrée au
souvenir et à la famille et où les
déplacement par route sont nombreux et
mettons au crédit de la démocratie cette
pagaille dans un régime totalitaire en
effet une telle décision
augmenter le prix de l'essence et prises
et appliquées
du jour au lendemain pour la bonne
raison qu'il n'ya pas de parlement ou
que s'il y en a un on lui demande pas
son avis en politique la semaine sera
essentiellement consacré à la suite du
débat budgétaire et à la préparation des
élections partielles la première
sélection a lieu dimanche à brioude dans
la haute loire les autres sont fixé au
14 au 21 novembre
jacques chirac l'ancien premier ministre
et cinq anciens membres de son
gouvernement vont tenter de retrouver
leur siège de député à la veille des
élections municipales et dans le
contexte politique actuel dans ce débat
qui est largement ouvert ce sont des
élections que l'on va suivre avec
beaucoup d'intérêt tant du côté de la
majorité que de celui de l'opposition
et puis
un procès qui va sans doute faire un
certain bruce cette semaine celui d'un
grand professeur de médecine daniel
morel fassions on lui reproche comme au
professeur jules guesde et des
simulations fiscales très importante
le professeur morel faciaux qui est
membre de l'académie de chirurgie a déjà
déclaré qu'il ne s'était aperçu de la
dissimulation qui lui est reprochée
qu'en consultant sa comptabilité tenue
jusqu'à lors par un conseil fiscal à
l'étranger en attend surtout au liban un
certain nombre de changements cette
semaine avec l'arrivée d'une force arabe
de 30000 hommes qui doit aider le
président sarkis à rétablir l'ordre et à
mettre en application si possible
l'accord de riad a prouvé au caire mais
depuis quelques jours les difficultés
politiques ne cessent de s'accumuler
avec en particulier le rendez vous
manqué hier entre les délégués
conservateur et palestine aux
progressistes de plus le cessez le feu
reste extrêmement précaire à beyrouth
plusieurs dizaines de libanais ont été
tués ces jours derniers
pour la première fois depuis
l'unification du vietnam deux
personnalités de hanoi en visite à paris
monsieur total vice ministre des
affaires étrangères accompagnée d'un
haut fonctionnaire était accueilli ce
matin par l'ambassadeur du vietnam à
paris des entretiens franco vietnamiens
vont débuter mercredi avec monsieur
louis ii guy ringot ministre français
des affaires étrangères ils ont pour but
de normaliser les rapports entre paris
et hanoï rapport qui ont besoin d'être
redéfinie depuis la réunification des
deux vietnam
voici lee yen yen vice premier ministre
chinois dont des affiches murales à
shanghai annoncé ce matin la promotion
comme premier ministre pour remplacer
web pour fang devenu officiellement
successeur de mario mais ce soir là jean
chine nouvelle dément la nomination de
lee hsien mienne d'après chine nouvelle
il n'y a aucun changement dans le
gouvernement chinois wako feng reste
premier ministre et line tienne yens son
adjoint
ian smith claque la porte à genève le
premier ministre rob des siens estiment
que la conférence sur l'avenir de son
pays
piétine il rentre donc chez lui mercredi
et d'en revenir en suisse que si les
négociations font des progrès d'autre
part des troupes rhodésienne importantes
auraient pénétré au mozambique pays
voisins si l'on en croit l agence de
presse officielle du mozambique capté à
lisbonne des troupes équipées de chars
de canons et de bombardier avancerait à
l'intérieur du pays
pas de divorce entre niki lauda et la
firme ferrari après l'abandon du pilote
autrichien au grand prix du japon une
menace sérieuse avait pesé sur leur
association menace dissiper enzo ferrari
annoncé lui même que le contrat de lauda
avait été reconduit pour un an
un changement toutefois dans l'écurie
carlos reutemann devient second pilote à
la place de clay regazzoni
un seul résultat sportif à vous signaler
ce soir l'équipe australienne de rugby à
15 les wallabies a suivi subi une
nouvelle défaite à bourg-en-bresse dans
l'ain face à une sélection régionale
française
score final 25 à 7 les wallabies ont
quitté la france après pas mal de
déboires pas mal de défaites ils ont
perdu en particulier vous le savez les
deux test matches contre l'équipe de
france et puis il y avait un tiercé
aujourd'hui à auteuil le second du
week-end tierces et très mouvementée
dans le grand steeple chase réservé aux
4 ans et qui se disputait sur 4400
mètres 13 partants et à l'arrivée dans
l'ordre mais après réclamation le dise
le 7 et le 3 alors que les treize
concurrents du prix maurice gillois
francis est le deuxième obstacle sous la
conduite de wuala dana le grand favori
chine comptes tombaient au grand
désappointement de ses nombreux
supporters après le saut de la rivière
du 8
voilà dana le 1 était toujours en tête
devant le clou laurent hélas mire pour
aborder la rivière les tribunes les
positions n'avaient pas varié
tous les chevaux passer cet obstacle
sans en cours dans un bon magnifique au
milieu de la ligne d'en face
wallah dana accélérait encore la lure
toujours suivi de l'autre laurent pêne à
berne est monté chat on à bord dont le
dernier tournant voilà dana qui
faisaient une course extraordinaire
maintenait son avance devant penvern
d'hilton et nuque la démo c'est sur le
dernier obstacle pennavayre ne cède 0,20
brutalement devant nutella des noms le
disent les deux chaumette une lutte
magnifique du pennavienne sortait
vainqueur un court instant d'ailleurs
puisque après réclamation il était
rétrogradé très sévèrement par les
commissaires à la seconde place au
profit de l'udc a donné le tiercé le
douce le sait et le 3
donnent tous les quatre ans et toujours
le mardi qui suit le premier lundi 2
novembre les américains choisissent
corps président alors vous le savez
jamais chouanard a été aussi difficile
presque aventureux ford carter carter
ford
les américains pensent qu'ils auraient
pu tomber mieux car aucun des deux
candidats ne leur laisse l'impression
que le prestige de leur pays sera bien
défendu avec ford ou avec carter les
deux hommes ne s'efface même pas
derrière les programmes de leur parti au
contraire c'est ford s'écartèrent que
les américains ont vu et entendu pendant
dix mois de campagne électorale
mais à la veille du scrutin combien
d'américains connaissent jimmy carter et
de gerald ford
être président c'est donc endossé toute
l'histoire de son pays
même si on n'est pas un président élu
nous visitons la maison blanche à
l'occasion et vincent car j'éprouve du
respect et de l'attachement pour
l'histoire de mon pays
je crois que beaucoup de choses
importantes se passe ici à la maison
blanche c'est pourquoi je veux
simplement passer quelques instants ici
vice président élu après le départ de
spiro agnew pour corruption président
non élu
après le départ de richard nixon pour
corruption et mensonges
ainsi se résume la marche de ford vers
la maison blanche depuis le 9 août 1974
le président des états unis et donc
gerald ford
avec derrière lui vingt bonnes années de
vie parlementaire débonnaire honnête
parsemé de chute ou de gaffes qui
naturellement peuvent altérer dit et
qu'on se fait là président ford à
trouver et garder à ses côtés l'homme de
la politique étrangère américaine
il s'appelle henry kissinger et henry
kissinger a poursuivi vers l'extérieur
sa politique amorcée déjà sous nixon et
ford a écouté son imposant ministre
alors l'europe négligé voire malmené le
retrait du vietnam ou la
non-intervention en angola
est-ce ford ou kissinger
là des 76 allait inévitablement être
difficile pour gérald fort nous voyons
surgir un rival républicain pur et dur
on al reagan à caen à six pieds au mois
d'août ford et carter reagan de la
course à l'élection le président non élu
et donc élue cette fois ci pour discuter
la course à la maison blanche
c'est une victoire capitale mais
incertaine
cependant gerald ford et qu'il est entré
en fonctions ici à la maison blanche n'a
eu qu'une seule idée en tête se faire
réélire comme président exactement ce
qu'avait fait romana la mort de
roosevelt à la fin de la guerre mondiale
car il est prouvé que les présidents
sortants aux états unis qui veulent se
faire réélire réussissent assez aisément
il n'y a eu que cinq ou six échecs en
dieu siècles d'histoire et depuis la
guerre en tout cas tous on réussit
romane je viens de le dire mais aussi
roosevelt et même nixon alors pourquoi
pas le tranquille député du michigan
à moins d'être inconsciemment anti ford
pour ceux qui lient le président au
vietnam et au watergate
l'américain du middle-west par exemple
pourra noter que la période ford fut une
période sans guerre mais aussi sans
imagination aux promesses de son
adversaire ford peut répondre qu'il a
pour lui l'expérience du pouvoir et que
sa vision du monde correspond à celle de
la mairie de 1976 l'isolationnisme à
peine cachée au prix d'un dialogue
régulier avec moscou et la volonté de
combattre
à l'intérieur les inégalités et le
chômage
et l'amérique qui ne connaît pas carter
croit-elle en forme
2 novembre 1976 et peut être la nouvelle
la plus extraordinaire avec un nouveau
président des états unis 51 ans fermiers
ingénieurs officier de marine physicien
nucléaire chrétiens américains
ainsi se définit lui même james lockhart
on l'attend quand je pense à des gens
comme moi shilton ou lincoln par exemple
je n'arrive pas à les imaginer en chair
et en os et aujourd'hui penser que
quelqu'un qui met une aussi petite ville
de géorgie pourrait leur succéder
et bien que ce soit moi ou le reste des
vacances cela ne bouleverse complètement
ce jour-là new york
il manie l'humour en annonçant qu'il est
candidat et que tout le monde sait et il
donne le nom de son colistier pour la
course à la maison blanche
walter mondale
carter devient donc le 16 juillet 76 le
porte drapeau du parti démocrate
sa petite fille a mis le cheveux flous
la démarche dégagé suffit style art y
incarnez john fitzgerald kennedy dont
jimmy carter c'est ici à plein géorgie
680 habitants que carter a entouré sa
démarche vers le pouvoir
jimmy ou jimmy qui est ce on dit très
vite de lui ses ennemis en voyant cet
homme de la province bousculer les idées
reçues à washington encouragé par sa
femme et aussi par sa mère
anticonformiste pour un habitant de
plaine ce et assister surtout d'une
équipe de jeunes géorgiens dont la
moyenne d'âge est celle de jodie powells
33 ans
son porte-parole gouverneur de géorgie
il ya six ans
le premier dans cet état du sud profond
il a fait savoir avec des doigts que
pour lui un noir égale un blanc
démocrates du sud
pas comme les autres qui s'arrêtent
devant la photo de martin luther king
jimmy carter au sourire clair mais au
programme flou même à quelques jours du
verdict après lovers truman kennedy
sera-t-il le 39e président des états
unis et de qui est il le successeur
averell harriman un homme politique
d'expérience qui a connu roosevelt
compare même carter à roosevelt
on me pose souvent la question est bien
carter me fait penser à rospez jeudi
roosevelt parce qu'il a des idées neuves
parce qu'il s'intéresse au sort des gens
à ceux qui sont dans le besoin
roosevelt s'intéressait à l'humanité je
crois que carter le fera aussi et qu'il
sera une grande figure de notre histoire
fait grève mais des trois débats
télévisés aussi tôt et trop rapidement
comparé au précédent kennedy nixon en
carter n'a pas caché hier l'homme
nouveau sinon sont apparus chez l'homme
la ferveur moral l'inexpérience bien
souvent la volonté de défendre le
consommateur
pas de message keynésien donc mais ses
appuis ont été l'énorme appareil
démocrate avec edward kennedy ici la
convention de juillet et le très
puissant maire de chicago richard daley
mais dans quelques jours s'il est élu
carter devra peut-être découvrir son jeu
devant des adversaires qui s'appelle
politique étrangère inflation
dissémination nucléaire chômage
alors on saura qui interpellent un homme
habile et volontaire parvenu tout
simplement pouvoir ou au contraire un
grand président
mais l'amérique elle c'est elle reconnu
dans l'image du mystérieux monsieur
carter
je vous rappelle ou plutôt je vous
signale car on ne l'a pas encore
beaucoup dit qu'en ce qui concerne ces
élections présidentielles américaines et
avant de voir la météo est bien que
demain les dossiers de l'écran après le
journal leur seront entièrement
consacrés avec d'abord un documentaire
la maison blanche pourquoi pas réaliser
par adolphe faudrait ensuite un film de
michael ritchie voter mackay et enfin un
débat sur ces élections elles mêmes
et puis mercredi après les résultats
jean lefebvre en direct de washington
animera une édition spéciale de
l'actualité avec un certain nombre de
personnalités américaines et de
journalistes le temps donc maintenant il
sera généralement couvert et pluvieux
sur la moitié ouest de la france avec
des vents de sud ouest assez fort
surtout sur les côtes dans le midi
méditerranéen les éclaircies
prédomineront sur les autres régions le
temps sera nuageux avec des éclaircies
passagères voilà avec toute la rédaction
d'antenne 2 je vous remercie d'avoir
suivi cette édition du journal bonsoir
excellente soirée à tous et tout de
suite le rappel des principaux titres de
l'actualité retour sans trop de
difficultés sur les routes de la
toussaint essence plus cher à minuit des
pompes fermées ou à sec aujourd'hui 17 3
le tiercé rapporte 2400 francs environ
ford léger avantage sur carter à la
veille de l'élection
bien mieux journal 23h30 après l'huile
sur le feu